oh
[Music]
where's it
is
come on buddy
she's black where's the last place she
was at i don't know
okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
cricket
cricket
cricket
cricket
cricket
cricket
cricket
cricket
come here cricket come here
i'm gonna cricket
[Music]
all right
oh dude it's like way down
he's coming this way is it a little bit
okay keep doing whatever you're doing
there you go
are always you know
oh man my hero
all of you
thank you yeah that's a baby thank you
so very much
hey look at here stanley you got a
blanket to catch it
hey we catch that sucker yeah
well we can trust me
i can get that cat down hold this
blanket
hold it out wide
now you let that cat fall that's your
fault
[Music]
all right
now come my way a little bit
i'm gonna try to shake it yeah
come my way just
just for a second so i can get a hold of
this
[Music]
all right you ready
[Music]
come on down cat i'll wait a little bit
come on cat
got it
come on
what you know about that
we got that cat
there's more than one way to catch a cat
he's skinny oh you know now somebody
coming back here
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nice job
he's happy to see you yeah he is
okay real careful get you not the dog
you see what you can do to get under him
he'll do the most of the work
with your left arm
yeah don't tie the door easy for us to
say right
we've got the
[Music]
but don't tie him in
just grab his butt shove him up
come on watson come on watson you got it
buddy
oh there you go all right
all right just relax davey
come here cucho
good job watching
[Music]
oh good boy
[Applause]
[Applause]
give me anything with a leash
can you sister this one this one's going
out okay
give me this one come on come on baby
oh come here
oh come here baby
come on can you walk
come out all the way around the back
you'll see us we're with you
oh come on
come on
come on
okay this one
may not be able to walk out
let's go
come on come on
[Applause]
[Music]
okay double check there
and be ready for any more come on
come on
come on
oh there we go
good girl
go down
good girl
oh my god
hey everybody
okay
good girl
come here kona
oh my god
[Music]
ready
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys
oh my god
daisy
okay
oh
go the other way
go the other one
come on
[Applause]
she's tired just give her a minute and
then maybe we could get her up there
yeah
just out of this cold water come on baby
all right davey we got it
[Applause]
engine 44
we gotta get back to work
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]